Donald Trump bragged today that he was
responsible for Ford's decision to
invest 1.2 billion dollars in new jobs
in Michigan Trump tweeted about it this
is his actual tweet big announcement by
Ford today major investment to be made
in three Michigan plants car companies
coming back to us jobs jobs jobs yeah
but Ford says they had actually planned
that long before Trump's election now
folks this is nothing new
ok if you look at President Trump's past
tweets he's taking credit for a lot of
things that he had nothing to do with
check it out for example just greenlit
another season of NFL football look for
it yeah look at this one it was I alone
who made spring start on March 20th look
at the flowers huge success huge huge
look at this one Albertsons supermarket
is selling pork loin for an incredible
399 per pound who said I can't close a
great deal hashtag or the deal hashtag
pork
there you go two great Americans margin
Tom Erikson a st. Paul had fantastic
sense last night my idea
and finally my idea for Jesus to rise
again he owes me big li hashtag Cadbury
eggs
[Applause]
you